ก็
สวัสดีค่ะคุณต้อมสวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋สวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียน
ทุกคนด้วยค่ะแค่กูต้องสบายดีไหมคะพี่ต้อม
สบายดีค่ะตัวเองนะคะเออสบายดี
สบายดีคิดก่อนนะกินด้วยนะ
โอเคค่ะเดี๋ยวเราขอเขียนวันที่ก่อนนะคะ
อ้าวคุณต้อมคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
อาทิตย์ค่าครูเอ๋ไปคุยเขียนไม่ได้ก็
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์ร้านเหรอขาดวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่ 15 ค่ะครูเอ๋วันที่ 15 ไป
ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
พฤษภาคมค่ะ
เดือนพฤษภาคมเมื่อ
ปีพตตตะรังไข่คะดีข้อ
2022 ค่ะ 2 คัน 22 ปีคศปีพตขอ
[เพลง]
ตั้งเวลาตอนกลางคืนใช่ไหมคะคุณต้องให้ค่า
เป็นเวลากลางคืนแล้วมืดแล้วแห่กลางคืนก็
มีอะไรคะ
บางคืนมีพระจันทร์
สวยงามแต่มีพระจันทร์นะคะพระจันทร์สี
เหลืองขาวคุณต้องบอกว่าอาจารย์สวยห้องสวย
มากค่ะสวยงาม
เป็นยังไงถ้าสวยงาม
สวยงามคือสวยมากสดใส
สวยมากแล้วครับคุณตอบสวยงามสวยมากนะคะ
แล้วก็มีดาวนะคะมีดาวนะคะโอเคนะคะวันนี้
วันอาทิตย์ล่ะคะตอนกลางคืนครูเอกกับครู
ต้องเจอกันค่ะนักเรียนอาเดี๋ยวกูเห็นลบ
ตรงนี้ก่อนนะคะคุณต้อมาน We  are  a คุณ
ตั้มคะออดคลิปที่แล้วเราพูดถึงว่าครูต้อม
เนี่ยกูต้อมเนี่ยอ่ะคุณพ่อ
คุณแม่ของคุณต้อมน่ะเป็นคนไทยอันนี้ก็คน
ไทยคนไทย
100% เนาะครูต้อมก็เลยเป็นคนไทย
100% ไทยใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะถ้าครูต้องคนไทย
100% แต่ครูเอ๋เนี่ยก็จะเป็นภัยแต่แป๊บ
ทีน
ครูเอ๋เป็นครึ่งไทยครึ่งจีนเป็นลูกครึ่ง
ไหมถ้าลูกครึ่งจึงจริงๆตอนนี้ก็ไม่ลูก
ครึ่งเลือดใช่มั้ยตรงนี้แล้วบอกแล้วอ่ะ
เลือดเลื่อนอ่ะภัยจีนแบบพาสปอร์ตหรือไอดี
ก็เป็นคนไทยนะคะเราบอกว่ามีเชื้อชาติไทย
จีน
สัญชาติคือในพาสปอร์ตที่เขียนไว้ก็บอก
สัญชาติไทยสัญชาติไทยครูต้อมเสื้อชาติให้
ในสัญชาติภัยไอ้นะคะ
ทำไมกูอ่ะพูดไทยจีนเพราะว่าอย่างนี้ค่ะ
นักเรียนเพราะว่าคนไทยเนี่ยคนไทยนะคะก็จะ
ชอบไปวัดเนาะอันนี้เป็นวัด
ไปวัดนะคะแต่คุยวัดแบบนี้ล่ะคะที่วัดก็จะ
มีพระทำไมฉายอ่ะที่วัดราคาตอนจะมีพระ
นิดพระอะไรคะครูต้อม
รักสงฆ์ค่ะหน้าพระสงฆ์นะคะพระสงฆ์ก็จะใส่
ชุดสีสีเหลืองสี
สีส้มสีส้มผักแต่เราพูดสีเหลืองใช่ค่ะเรา
พูดว่าผ้าเหลืองนะชุดของพระเนี่ยสีเหลือง
นะแต่ดูนะสีส้มราคาให้ค่ะกูต้องคะเวลาคุณ
ต้อมเด็กๆครูต้อม
ไป
ขอโทษค่ะเอาปากกามากไปวัดไหมคะไปวัดค่า
ตอนครูต้องเด็กๆไปรถบ่อยค่ะ 5 ค่ะคุณต้อง
ไปทำอะไรที่วัดค่ะ
รู้ต้องไปไหว้พระค่ะไหว้พระสงฆ์หรือไหว้
พระอันนี้คะเดี๋ยวคุยว่างให้พระพุทธรูป
อันนี้ราคานักเรียน
ข้างในวัดตอนจะมี
มีอันนี้คุยใกล้สีน้ำเงินนิเรียกรูปภาพ
พระพุทธรูปพระพุทธรูปเนี่ยเดินได้ไหมคะ
เดือนไม่ได้ค่ะพระพระพุทธรูปเดินไม่ได้
พระสงฆ์เดินได้ให้ค่ะเพราะว่าพระสงฆ์เป็น
คนและพระพุทธรูปเนี่ยปั้นนะคะเป็นรูปเรา
บอกว่ารูปปั้นนะคะแต่เป็นรูปปั้นพระ
พุทธรูปกูต้องไปไหว้พระพุทธรูปพระพุทธรูป
หรือว่าให้พระสงฆ์คะดูต้อมไหว้ 2 อย่าง
ค่ะพระพุทธรูป
พระสงฆ์ก็ไปไหว้พระนะคะมีมีอาหารไหมคะคุณ
ต้องมีอาหารไหมมีอาหารด้วยค่ะมีเกล็ดข้าว
มีอาหารแล้วก็เอาไปทำบุญใช่ไหมคะให้ค่ะ
เอาไปทำบุญ
สวิทซ์ตอนเราเด็กๆนะคะนักเรียนเวลาเราโต
โตๆเราพูดต้องเรียนไปวัดนะคะ
ตอนโตคือต้องก็ไปวัดค่ะของยังไปวัดนะคะ R
ที่นี้เนี่ยนักเรียนคะที่วัดยังมีพระ
พุทธรูปมีพระสงฆ์บางวัดเนี่ยก็จะมีมีแบบ
นี้มีแม่ชีรึ
[เพลง]
ใช่ไหมคุยแต่ว่าถูกไหม
แล้วมีเสื้อในสีเสื้อโอเค
แม็กชี่นะคะแม่ชีนะคือผู้หญิงใช่ไหมคะพี่
ตั้มแม่ชีน่ะเป็นผู้หญิงแล้วก็โกนผมน้าก็
ใส่พุธสีอะไรครับคุณต้อมใส่ชุดสีขาวค่ะสี
ขาวนะคะเราเรียนเราเรียกว่าแม่ชีนะคะนะ
ครับแต่ว่าที่วัดมีพระมีพระพุทธรูปมีพระ
มีแม่ชีครูเอ๋หน้าเคยเห็นครูต้อมเคยเห็น
ผู้หญิงนะคะผู้หญิงทำผมแบบนี้แล้วก็ใส่
แบบนี้อะ
แล้วก็เป็นกระโปรงแบบนี้นะก็มีผ้าสีขาว
อันนี้เรียกว่าแม่ชีไหมคะอันนี้ไม่ใช่แม่
ชีค่ะครูเอ๋
เรียกว่าอะไรอเมริกาว่า
พราหมณ์ค่ะเรียกว่าชีพราหมณ์ล่ะให้ขายที
ไม่มีสีไหม
ที่ผ่านก็ได้
เป็นโยคีก็ได้ค่ะอ๋ออันนี้คือคือคนทั่วไป
อ่ะคะนักเรียนเออถ้าเป็นผู้ชายหรือผู้
หญิงนะคะที่ไปวัดแล้วก็ใส่ชุดสีขาวอ่าน
อยู่ที่วัด 2 วัน 3 วันหรือบางที 7 วัน
หรือ 10 วันก็ได้นะคะเราจะบอกว่าบวช
พราหมณ์ใช่ไหมคะหายค่ะบวชพราหมณ์แต่ว่า
ตอนนี้เขาไม่ให้เรียกปวดครามและคุณต้อม
เพราะว่าบวชเนกขัมมะ
โอ้โห
ตอนนี้นะตอนนี้กูเอกก็เลยงงๆๆเวลาคู๋เด็ก
ๆคนไทยจะบ่อ๊อดฉันไปวัดไปบวชชีพราหมณ์ค่ะ
บวชชีพราหมณ์คือผมแนะยังมีผมยาวได้ยายใส่
ชุดสีขาวแตะลิปสติกมีได้ไหมคะไม่ได้ค่ะ
อ๋อไม่ทาลิปสติกนะคะบวชชีพราหมณ์คุณต้อง
เคยไปบวชไหมคะ
เฮ้ยค่าซ่อมเคยไปบวชนะกี่วันคะโอ๊ยเจ็บ
วันถ้า 7 วันอะเดี๋ยวกูอ่ะลบอันนี้ก่อนนะ
คะนักเรียน
Bag ที่ออกก่อนจบไปเนี่ย
อุ้ยขอโทษค่ะ
เอ้าคุยทำใหญ่เกินไปนะคะ
โอเค
ลบเสร็จแล้วคุณต้องไปบวชไปบวช 7 วัน
แล้วคุณต้องใส่ชุดแบบนี้ไหมคะใส่ชุดสีขาว
แบบนี้ค่ะมีเสื้อหน่วยงานเสื้อแขนยาวใช้
ค่ะแล้วก็ผ้าถุง
ใช่ไหมคะสีขาว
หูที่ไหนคะกรุงเทพฯหรือต่างจังหวัด
กรุงเทพฯค่ะขอที่กรุงเทพฯนะคะคะใช่ค่ะ
แล้วเวลากูต้องไปบวชเนี่ยกินอาหารกี่มื้อ
อิ่มอาหาร 2 มื้อค่ะ 2 มื้อเหมือนพระใช่
ไหมคะ
รักกินอาหาร 1 มื้อค่ะ 1 มื้อ 500 ขอคิด
ก่อนนะคะโอ้พระก็กิน 2 มื้อค่ะครูเอ๋พระ
เราไม่พูดกินกูต้องฉันพระเนี่ยฉันอาหาร
สองมื้อแต่ว่างวัดบางวัดแน่น 1 มื้อ
บางวัดนะคะอ้าบางวันบางวัดก็ 2 มื้อบาง
วัดก็หนึ่งหมื่นวัดที่ครูต้อมไปบวชคราม
เนี่ยพระฉันอาหารกี่มื้อนะคะ 1 มื้อ
สองมื้อค่ะ 2 เมตรนะคะค่ะว่าทำไมครูเอ๋
ถามคุณต้อมว่าทำไมไปบวชใช่ไหมคะอ่ะกูยัง
ไม่ได้ถามคุณต้องทำไมครูต้องไปบวช
เนกขัมมะ
อ๋อครูต้องไปบวชเพราะกูต้องคิดว่า
ความดีความดีกับความไม่ดี
เหมือนกันไหม
หืม
งมั่ยคะนักเรียนงงค่ะกูเองไม่งง
กูต้อมพูดแบบมองเห็นภาพค่ะกูตอบดีอะดีนะ
เป็นยังไงคดีเนี่ย
คนนึงได้ไหม
กูอธิบายให้
คือคือกูตั้มคิดว่าถ้าไปบวชอยู่ในชุดสี
ขาวกินอาหาร
อ่าวัน 2 ครั้งอันนี้ทำดีดีใช่ไหมคะใช้
ค่าทำดีนักเรียนเวลาคนไทยไปบวชก็คือใส่
ชุดสีขาวเราก็ไหว้พระแล้วก็นามอเตอร์ไซค์
บนนะคะค่ะสวดมนต์ตอนเช้า
เราก็ตอนเย็นนะคะตั้งแต่ประมาณตี 4 ไหมมี
4 ค่ะตี 4 นะคะ 4:00 นอ่ะก็จะหน้า
มอเตอร์ไซค์สวดมนต์นานนะคะนักเรียนจะสวด
มนต์นานๆตั้งแต่ตี 4 อันนี้ครั้งที่ 1 นะ
คะครั้งที่ 2  5 โมงเย็นไหมคะเดี๋ยว 6:00
น
6:00 ค่ะอันนี้ครั้งที่ 1 นะคะครั้งที่ 2
18:00 นสาวๆสวดมนต์แต่
กะกลางวันเนี่ยนักเรียนขากลางวันเนี่ยก็
คือจะเดิน
เดินแล้วก็นั่งนั่งสมาธินั่งสมาธิก็คือ
เอามือนะคะนักเรียนมือเนี่ยเหตุกันแล้วก็
วางข้างล่างแล้วก็หายใจเข้าคิดอะไรคะ
ของครูต้อมเรียนเนี่ย
หายใจเข้ากลุ่มของค่ะยุบหนอพองหนอหายใจ
เข้าก็พองหนอหายใจออกก็ยุบรุกหนอโอเคท้อง
พองท้องยุคใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะยุคนะคะอันนี้มี
คนไทยเยอะๆไปบวชเพราะว่าบวชแล้วรู้สึก
คนดีใช่ไหมคะเราไปบวชพระบวกพราหมณ์หรือ
บวชเนกขัมมะเป็นคนดีคุณต้อมแนว 5-7 วัน
เก่งมากทำ
กูต้องคะ 7 วันเนี่ยบวชเสร็จแล้ว
มีความสุขไหมค่ะมีความสุขค่ะสุดนะคะที่
นี้เนี่ยคุณต้อม
คู๋มีเรื่องจะเล่าให้คุณต้องฝันอ่ะนะคะ
วัดคู่นะอ่ามีเรื่องจะเล่าให้ฟัง
กูต้องเคยได้ยินไหม
คนบวชเขามีเรื่องเล่าว่าคนบวชคนบวชน่ะได้
บุญน้อยกว่าคนตกปลา
ครูต้องไม่เคยได้ยินเลยค่ะ
คู๋นะไปอ่านว่ะว่าแล้วก็คู๋จริงๆไม่ได้
อ่านอย่างเดียวมีคนพูดพูดพูดให้ครูเอ๋ฟัง
บอกว่าบางทีคนคนนะคะไปบวชไม่ใช่บวชพระนะ
คะบวชอันเนี้ยก็ได้บุญคือเราไปบวชเรารู้
สึกได้บุญนักเรียนตัวเองบุญคืออะไรบุญก็
คือดีนะคะค่ะดีคนไทยชอบไปวัดทำบุญแล้วก็
รู้สึกได้บุญนะคะที่นี้เนี่ยก็มี
เรื่องเรื่องเล่าเกี่ยวกับบุญน่ะมากๆแต่
มีเรื่องหนึ่งอันนี้กูอาจจะเล่าให้คุณ
ต้องฟังนะคะเป็นเรื่องของคอนนะผู้หญิง 1
คนนะผู้หญิงคนนี้แหละผู้หญิงผู้หญิงไปวัด
ที่วัดเนี่ยใกล้ๆวัดก็มีแม่น้ำ
หมีแม่น้ำนะคะ
มีแม่น้ำ
ขอโทษค่ะ
มีน้ำนี้นะครับที่วัดก็มีแม่น้ำ
ถ้าเราก็นี่เป็นโบสถ์ใช่ไหมคะทีนี้ตรงนี้
จะมีศาลาอ่ะศาลาสำหรับเป็นศาลาสำหรับคน
ที่มาแล้วก็นั่งนัดคนเนี่ยผู้หญิงคนนี้ก็
จะมาอยู่ที่นี่นั่งนะคะนั่งสมาธิหรือ
บางทีเดิน
เดินเดินๆไม่ใช่แบบนี้นะคะเดินเอามือไว้
ข้างหลังแล้วก็เดินยุคหนอพองหนอ
ที่คุณต้อมเดินได้ค่ะอ๋อพองหนอ
อ่ะขา
ที่นี้เนี่ยกูต้องเวลาเราเห็นคนไปบวช
เนี่ยรู้สึกดีไหมคะรู้สึกดีค่ะกูต้องชอบ
ไหมเวลาเห็นคนไปบวชก็ฆ่าปลอมใช่ไหมคะๆคุณ
ต้องคุยกับกูเอได้เลยนะคะกู
แต่คุณต้องเวลาเห็นเวลาครูต้องไปบวชน่ะ
เขาให้พูดไหมเวลาที่หูต้องไปบวชเขาจะไม่
ให้พูดมีโทรศัพท์ได้ไหมคะไม่ได้ค่ะคลิป
สาดไปรักษาเก็บค่ะหาลิปสติกได้ไหมคะมิติ
พาไม่ได้ทาเล็บได้ไหมคะ
ทาเล็บอากาศถ้าอยู่แล้วก่อนที่จะเข้าไป
บวชก็ไม่เป็นไรค่ะค่ะทาแป้งไม่ได้
เขียนคิ้วได้ไหมเลี้ยงคิ้วไม่ได้โง่นะคะ
ไม่มีแฟชั่นใช่ไหมคะนี่ค่ะรักที่นี้เนี่ย
กูตามเวลาที่กูตามบวชใช่ไหมเราก็ต้องคิด
ถึงยุบหนอพองหนอคิดถึงคิดถึงนะคะนักเรียน
คิดคิดคิดถึงพระพุทธเจ้านะคะเราเพราะก็
คิดอยู่อาซ้อพองหนอราคาที่นี้
กูซ่อมดูอย่างอื่นด้วยนะ
กูต้องไปคิดยุบพองยุบพองตาดูอย่างอื่น
ด้วยค่ะอ๋อเวลาเวลาคุณต้อมนั่งเนี่ยรู้
สึกโอ๊ตเขาจะนั่งนะนั่งแบบนี้เมื่อยไหม
เมื่อยมากค่ะเมื่อยวันที่ 1 เมื่อยวันที่
2 นะคะเฮ้ยมากกว่าวันที่สาวล่ะคะเมื่อ
ที่สดวันที่ 4 เริ่มไม่เมื่อยแล้วค่ะโอเค
วันที่ 5 โอเคสบายมากวันที่ 6
ปีที่ 5 วันที่ 7
กลับบ้าน
เอาไว้ดีใจมีความสุขแล้วค่ะกูต้องมีความ
สุขแล้วก็อยากกลับบ้านค่ะอีก 3 วันวันที่
1 เนี่ยมือไง
เมื่อยวันที่ 2 หายล่ะคะวันที่ 3 กลับ
บ้านอ้าวหรอคะ
คิดอย่างนี้นักเรียนคะคือเวลาเราไปบวชน่ะ
แล้วก็จะรู้สึกสบายใจนะสบายงั้นเนี่ยผู้
หญิงคนเนี้ยก็เป็นก็ไปบวชแล้วก็นั่งที่
นี่ก็มีคนนะกูต้อมมีคนคนอยู่ที่นี่เยอะนะ
อ่านี่ที่วัดเยอะก็
เวลาเราบวชแล้วก็รู้สึกโอที่วัดต้องทำดีๆ
ใช่ไหมคะอย่างดีๆผู้หญิงนะเขาก็มองเห็น
ครับคุณต้อม
เขาไปมองเห็นผู้ชายคนหนึ่งนั่งอยู่
แล้วก็ตกปลา
คุณต้อมคุยมีคำถามถ้ากูจะไปบวชเนี่ยครับ
ปู๊ดต้องไม่เห็นผู้ชายตกปลาอยู่ที่แม่น้ำ
กูต้องคุณต้อมคิดอะไร
กูต้องคิดว่าเขากำลังหิวหรือเปล่าคะไม่
ได้หมายถึงคุณต้อมเนี่ยมองเห็นตอนนี้ตอน
นี้กูต้องอยู่ที่นี่นะอ่าอยู่ที่นี่ได้
ไหมคะคุณต้องหันไปเห็นคนตกปลากูต้องจะคิด
อะไรไหมคะหรือไม่คิดกูต้องคิดว่าเขากำลัง
หิวเอาปลาไปกินนะค่ะคุณตั้มก็คิดว่าเขา
กำลังหิวบ้าง
ค่ะ
กูต้องอยากรู้ไม่คุยคิดอะไรกูเองคิดอะไร
อยู่คะ
ก็คู๋ตอนกูเอกไปบวชนะคะตอนกูไปบวชเนี่ย
เก๋เห็นหลัก
ไม่คิด
กูอ่ะดูคลิปคะเออกำลังบวช
กูเอกกำลังบวชหันไปเห็นเห็นคนทาลิปสติก
เห็นคนถ่ายรูปเห็นคนตกปลาก็
ไม่คิดไม่คิด
เพราะว่าหิวสมาธิกำลังดวดคิดไม่ได้
เย็บยุบหนอพองหนอยุบหนอพองหนอหันไปเห็นก็
ยุบหนอพองหนอเราก็สั่งให้ Stars นะอยากทำ
มาเนี่ย
ก็คือก็คือคิดให้ปลาโชคดีผู้ชายชั่วที่จะ
หมักนี้
โอเคแล้วก็ยุบหนอพองหนอไม่คิดขิวไม่คิดทำ
อะไร
ไม่คิดหาเพราะว่าก็มีแม่ชีของกูเอกเป็น
แม่ชีแม่ชิมห้ามเห็นแล้วคิดอะไรเห็น
คนตกปลาโอเคแล้วก็สมาธินะฮะ
ไม่ไม่ต้องคิดนักเรียนอันนี้นะอันนี้กู
เติมนะคะเขาบอกว่าอย่างจริงๆอาจารย์ที่
สอนโกเอ๋เวลาเห็นแล้วไม่ต้องคิด
ก็เรากำลังเรียนนั่งสมาธิอะเรียนเดินนะคะ
นะเนี่ยไม่ต้องคิด
แต่เรื่องเนี้ยกูต้อมผู้หญิงคนเนี้ยผู้
หญิงผู้หญิงผู้หญิงคนนี้กำลังชุดสีขาว
แล้วก็นั่งสมาธิพอเห็นเห็นคอนตกปลาผู้
หญิงคนเนี้ยคิดว่า
มีคลิปอะไรคะผู้หญิงคนนี้คิดผู้ชายไม่ดี
ขอ
ทำไมตกปลาใกล้ๆวัด
เป็นคนไม่ดีมากๆทำอย่างนี้ไม่ได้โอนไร
เนี่ยทำไมเป็นคนไม่ดีถึงเกิดมาจนจนคือไม่
มีเงินมาตกปลาเนี่ยฉันคนดีฉันใส่ชุดสีขาว
อยู่ที่วัดชั้นคนดีผู้ชายคนไม่ดี
โกรธแล้วก็คิดคนไม่ดีคนไม่ดี
แต่ว่ากูต้อมรู้ไหมว่าผู้ชายคลิปอะไร
kitai คะเนี่ยผู้ชายนะคะนักเรียนผู้ชาย
เนี่ย
คิด
คุยคู๋ต้องลบตรงนี้ออกก่อน f  r ผู้ชายคน
นี้นะคะคุณเปลี่ยนผู้ชายคนนี้ก็คิด
นี่
ผู้ชายยิ้มค่ะ google กูไม่ใช่ใช่กำลังทำ
อะไรค่ะกำลังยิ้ม
ยิ้ม
ผู้ชายยิ้มผู้ชายคิดว่าโห
ทุกคนที่ศาลาศาลาอนิสาลาทุกๆคนที่ศาลาโชค
ดีมีเวลามานั่งสมาธิแล้วก็มาเดินเดินๆ
แล้วก็มาทำบุญใส่ชุดสีขาว
โชคดีจังเลย
โคไซน์สาธุสาธุ
ฉันเนี่ยเออตอนนี้โชคไม่ดีมีคุณพ่อ
คุณแม่แม่ไม่สบายไม่มีอาหารกินต้องมาตก
ปลาใช่ไหมจะปลาแล้วก็เอาปลาไปทำอาหารให้
คุณพ่อคุณแม่ที่ไม่สบายน่ะกินแล้วผู้ชาย
คนนี้นะครูต้อมเขาก็บอกว่า
บอกว่าอะไรรู้มั้ยบอกว่าอะไรคะขอโทษปลา
หมอ
เขาขอโทษปลาเพราะว่าปลาเนี่ยอ่ะโดนเข้า
ค่ายใช่ไหมคะเขาก็รู้สึกผิดขอโทษนะปลาถ้า
ไม่ฆ่าปลา
หิว
พ่อแม่ก็หิวก็ก็พ่อแม่ต้องกินโปรตีนใช่
มั้ยถ้าเราก็อดคิดแล้วก็สาธุสาธุก็จะ
ประมาณทำอาหาร
ก็สบายใจผู้ชายหลายใจคุณต้องคิดว่าผู้
หญิงสบายใจไหมกูต้องคิดว่าคู่หญิงไม่สบาย
ใจค่ะทำไมค่ะเพราะว่ากู้หญิงโปรดๆที่ผู้
ชายทำไม่ดีหนูปลา
งั้นไม่อาจปลา
กูต้อมเหตุการณ์นี้ใครได้บุญค่ะอ๋อเรื่อง
นี้คนตกปลาได้บุญนะคะเพราะว่าเขายิ้มมี
ความสุขค่ะย่อยอันนี้นะคะเขาสอนก็บอกว่า
เนี่ยคนตกปลาไม่ได้คิดค่าปลาแบบสนุกๆแต่
ไม่มีเงินนะคะก็ขอโทษปลาแล้วก็ปลาทำอาหาร
คิดถึงคุณพ่อคุณแม่นะครับเค้าก็เป็นเป็น
เรื่องนี้นิยายนิยายเกี่ยวกับนะฮะบอกว่า
คนนี้เปล่าเขาตายเขาก็ไปสวรรค์หน้า
ก็ตายเนี่ยเดี๋ยวกูเอานี่ลงไปเขาก็ไป
สวรรค์
นั้นเป็นคนไทยคิดมีเมฆแล้วก็มีวิมานอ้า
เรียกว่าวิมานแล้วก็ที่วิมานก็มีอะเทวดา
ใช่ไหมค่ะอันนี้เทวดาของประเทศนักเรียนนะ
คะ
เทวดาก็บอกผู้ชายคนเนี้ยตายแล้วก็ไป
สวรรค์ครับกูต่อม
เพราะว่าที่นี่คิดดีๆนะคะ
แต่คนนิสัยชุดสีขาวแต่คิดคนนั้นไม่ดีคน
นั้นไม่ดีคนนั้นไม่ดีคนนั้นไม่ดีคนนั้น
ไม่ดี
ผ้าใส่ชุดสีขาวอยู่วัดแต่คิดว่าอันนั้น
ไม่ดีไม่ดีไม่ดีใจน่ะใจก็ไม่ได้อยู่ที่
หมอ
เขาบอกว่าเนี่ยคนตกปลาได้ค่ะคุณต้อมใจน่ะ
อยู่ที่วัดแต่คนบวชถ้าใจอยู่ที่นี่ก็ไม่
ดีค่าสถานเนี่ยนักเรียนการบวชนะคะไม่ใช่
เฉพาะใส่ชุดสีขาวเท่านั้นนะคะจะต้องเอาใจ
อยู่ที่วัดด้วยคู๋ถึงถามกูต้องว่าเอ๊ะ
เวลากูต้มถ้าบวชแล้วเห็นคนตกปลาคิดอะไร
แต่พูดต้องบอกก็คิดว่าเขาหิวค่าเท่านั้น
ก็โอเคก็คิดว่าเขาอยู่จบก็โอเคแต่ถ้าคิด
ทำไมตกปลาที่วัด
อันนี้ไม่ดี
คือคือคือคิดได้หรือว่าเดินไปบอกก็ได้บอก
ว่าตรงนี้วัดนะคะไม่ตกปลาแต่ไม่โกรธไม่
ถึง
แต่ว่าถ้าโกรธเดี๋ยวทำไมทำอะไรโอ้โหอยู่
วัดแต่ใจร้อนอันนี้อันนี้ไม่ดีไม่ดีค่ะกู
เอกก็อ่านมาแล้วกูเอกก็
ชอบมากโอเคเอกไปตกปลาได้นะอย่าเพิ่งค่ะ
ไม่ได้
ไปตกปลาไม่ได้นะก็ขอโทษปลานะคะถ้างั้น
เนื้อการอะการบวชนะคะนักเรียนการบวชนะ
ครับปวดแล้วก็ต้องเอาใจอยู่ที่วัดด้วย
เรื่องนี้เขาก็สอนว่าเวลาเราไปวัดเนี่ย
เอาเอาใจเอาใจน่ะไปที่วัดด้วยไม่ใช่ตัว
อยู่วัดแล้วใจไปที่อื่นนะคะเรื่องตัวอยู่
วัดแล้วก็บอกว่าฉันทำบุญฉันคนดีอ่ะเธอไม่
ทำบุญเธอเป็นคนไม่ดี
ไปไปว่าคนอื่นไม่ดีสุดท้ายนะคะเพราะว่า
ผู้ชายตกปลาเขาทำดีไหมคะคุณต้อมผู้ชายตก
ปลาเขาอาจจะทำดีหรืออาจจะทำไม่ดีก็ได้ค่ะ
ในเรื่องนี้ค่ะพี่เขาตกปลาเนี่ยเขาทำดี
ไหมคะในวงศ์นี้เขาทำดีนะคะทำไมถึงทำดีคะ
ความดีเพราะว่าเขาเอาปลาเนี่ยไปกินแล้วก็
ไปให้พ่อให้แม่เขาจะได้แข็งแรงค่ะ
นักเรียนคะคุณพ่อคุณแม่ไม่สบายนะคะคือคุณ
อาจจะบอกว่าเอาไปตลาดซื้อ
คือเขาไม่มีเงินไม่มีเงินก็ไปแล้วซื้อไม่
ได้ยังไม่ห้ามซื้อไม่ได้แต่ถ้าเราไปตลาด
แล้วก็เอาปลา
แล้วคนตีหัวปลาโก๊ะผิดผิดชายค่ะเหมือนกับ
ผู้ชายคนนี้นะคะมีแล้วแต่ถ้าบางคนไม่กิน
ไม่กินปลาไม่กินหมูไอ้ออยไม่กินไก่อัน
นั้นก็โอเคเนาะ
นะแล้วแต่แต่ว่าอะไรคะกูทำใจผ่านใช่ไหมคะ
ครูเอ๋กินผักค่ะ
แต่ต้องดูดีๆนะบางคนกินผักกินผักแล้วไม่
สบาย
ก็ต้องกินปลาบ้านคู่เอกกินผักโอเคคุณต้อม
กินผักโอเคไหมโอเคนิดหน่อยสบาย
ไม่สบายต้องกินปลานะคะ
คุณพ่อไม่สบายคุณแม่ไม่สบายถ้าไม่เอาปลา
ไปให้กินคุณพ่อคุณแม่ก็อาจจะ
ตายมายงั้นเนี่ยเขาบอกมาห้ามนะคะ
ห้ามเราอยู่ในชุดสีขาวเราอย่าไปว่านี้นะ
คะว่าไม่ดีนะคะเอ๊ะหมดเวลาแล้วใช่ไหมครู
ต้อมห้องค่าหมดเวลาแล้วครับคุณเอ๋นัก
เรียนคะหมดเวลาแล้วแล้วโอกาสหน้าเก๋จะหา
นิทานนิทานธรรมะเราเนี้ยนิทานธรรมะมัน
เล่าให้ฟังอีกนะคะคลิปนี้กูเอกกับกูต้อง
ไปก่อนนะคะอ้าขอบคุณคู่เองนะคะ
สวัสดีนักเรียนค่ะบ๊ายบายน